okay Chuck
first to go what happened
you know honestly I was asking myself
the same thing going into last night I
was safe you know and they were all
taking James out something happened I
don't know if they something happen that
there's a break in the girls alliance
and last night and all of a sudden this
morning no one can look me in the eye
and they keep saying yeah you're fine
but I keep doing this one yeah you're
fine so what am I gonna do
everybody thinks Kisha went in on a deal
with you
for some reason and Omarosa and Kisha
are working together so everybody turned
on those two Shannon came to me with on
Omarosa to go in on you want to work
together I'm not sure okay perfect
Kisha did talk to me but I'm Lee and I
like Kisha we've been talking about food
and spices and he's just kitchen and all
that stuff but only deal we had was if
there was a tiebreaker and she picked me
I wouldn't put her up the first time I
got head of household so I really didn't
have a deal with her and I don't know if
I maybe I could have been more clear
with that with Shannon but I think it
was too late by that time fast paced
game paranoia took over very fast do you
have any regrets which her biggest
regret out of this experience
you know I maybe should have been a
little more conservative early and
trying to stretch that a little longer
because I'm really sad I was there for
the long haul of boredom and I'm missing
the fast-paced action part of it you
know I really wanted to do a few more
challenges and and there are a lot of
fun to do so you know I just wanted to
having a real shot at winning this thing
other than crappy you get kicked out so
soon are you happy you did this
experience it was overall great
experience I had a good time doing it
again I would really like another shot
at take it taking it a little further
but you know if they give me on The
Amazing Race
I'm in there we go well put it out there
you've told Julie you've told DT now
it's out in the universe you get to go
home and watch all this play out are you
gonna be tuning into those live episodes
what are you interested to see I'm
really interested to go back and see
what happened before and see if I read
everybody the way eventually I think I
read everybody right but I want to go
see if I made any mistakes and then I'm
gonna see what happens I I actually
didn't watch this show until I was asked
to do it but it's very interesting it's
fun to watch and then not personally
invested in these people it's gonna be a
lot more interesting who do you think is
gonna be the next big target in that
house Keisha and Omarosa are the big
targets I think right now yeah that
all-girls alliance came together real
fast fell apart real fast yeah but I'm
the casualty of war so I really sucks